[Applaudissements]
Je me retire bien dans ce cas qu'est-ce
qu'on boit pareil pour la filleule Dieu m'a
dit que tu as trouvé quelque chose
dans un train pendant la guerre un cadran qui
pourrait changer le cours de l'histoire pourquoi
tu poursuis ce qui a conduit
ton père  fou,
il va bouger s'il te plaît, sors d'ici,
arrête,
désolé
Dr Jones, récupère-le
[Musique]
Hitler a fait des erreurs et avec ça je
les corrigerai toutes tu l'as volé puis
tu l'as volé et puis je l'ai volé, ça
s'appelle le capitalisme
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
attache ta ceinture de sécurité il y a peut-être
des comprimés tu as tenté ta chance tu as
fait tes erreurs
maintenant un dernier Triumph
India donne-lui l'enfer Indiana Jones plusieurs
fois dans ma vie J'ai vu des choses que
je vais torturer avec du vaudou j'ai
été abattu neuf fois
dont une fois par ton père
ah je suis désolé
et j'ai cherché ça
toute ma vie
[Musique]